herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
sonder folge unseres bücher podcasts aus
dem literaturhaus frankfurt am 6 oktober
war dort bodo kirchhoff zu gast mit
seinem neuen roman bericht zur lage des
glücks es moderierte hubert spiegel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen schönen guten abend meine damen
und herren wir haben gerade schon gehört
bodo kirchhoff ist nicht ganz unbekannt
in frankfurt im fußball gibt es den
begriff des heimspiels das ist für die
heimmannschaft eine tolle sache
für den autor ist es glaube ich auch
eine tolle sache wenn er
ja so auf die ship mal sagen westkurve
die sich hier versammelt hat blicken
kann und davon ausgehen kann dass sind
alles leute die ihn kennen direkt einen
teil seines werkes das ganze werk es ist
sehr umfangreich das müssen sie nicht
alle kennen aber viele von ihnen werden
vieles kennen also ein heimspiel für den
autos das toll viele moderator ist
schrecklich denn es stürzt ihn in eine
identitätskrise
die äußert sich in einer frage und wo du
das ist die erste frage die ich heute
abend stelle aber die darfst du bitte
nicht beantworten denn die frage lautet
bin ich hier überhaupt nötig also werde
ich heute abend gebraucht braucht bodo
kirchhoff wenn er seinen neuen roman in
frankfurt vorstellt wirklich ein
moderator glaube ich glaube eigentlich
nicht
aber jetzt bin ich noch mal hier und
werde versuchen mich ein bisschen
nützlich zu machen
das buch ist sehr komplex das stimmt ich
glaube ich bringe aber die entsprechende
schlichtheit des gemüts mit die nötig
ist um das ein bisschen bisschen jetzt
für unsere zwecke heute abend ein
bisschen über schauerlicher
überschaubarer zu machen bevor wir zum
buch kommen vielleicht noch ein zwei
vorbemerkungen das werk stellte ich
jetzt nicht vor aber ich bin über eine
zahl gestolpert eine jahreszahlen und 70
kirchhoff lebt seit 1970 in frankfurt
hat also letztes jahr hätte wenn ich
corona gewesen wäre wahrscheinlich ein
rauschendes jubiläumsfest gefeiert
das hätte er eigentlich zusammen mit
seinem verleger machen können denn
letztes jahr 2020 hatte die frankfurter
verlagsanstalt ein jubiläum 25 jahre
zuvor hat zur frankfurter buchmesse
195 auch im umsätze ein erstes programm
vorgestellt zwei jubiläen das wollte ich
doch
zumindest erwähnen eingangs dieser
dieser buchpremiere ist ja eine
buchpremiere die erste öffentliche
lesung und ich will noch ein paar andere
premieren erwähnen ganz kurz das erste
buch das produkt kirchhoff
veröffentlichte war die novelle ohne
iphone ohne zorn und 179 der erste
bestseller war in fanta und 190
das erste drehbuch trug den titel
aus dem staub unser 82 geschrieben aus
mir völlig unverständlichen gründen
nicht verfilmt der erste schundroman
auch das gab es eine schuld roman von
bodo kirchhoff erschien 2002 und hieß
tatsächlich schon roman einige werden
sich noch erinnern
und das erste buch mit dem bodo
kirchhoff auf seine art auf die
flüchtlingskrise
reagiert hat
dies widerfahren ist und 2016 erschienen
ich hätte auch sagen können das erste
buch mit dem er den deutschen buchpreis
gewonnen hat dann hätten sie auch
gewusst wovon die rede ist bleiben wir
noch einen moment bei wieder fan ist es
gibt ja auffällige parallelen zwischen
den beiden büchern
unter anderem geht es um die folgen der
flüchtlingskrise aber ich will auch was
anderes hinaus ich will auf die
hauptfiguren hinaus
in widerfahren ist war die hauptfigur
und 2016 ein ehemaliger verlegung
zwei jahre davor 2014 verlangen und
melancholie war die hauptfigur ein
ehemaliger kulturredakteur
lokalpresse ja aber einer einer großen
frankfurter tageszeitung und jetzt in
bericht zur lage des glücks ist es
wieder ein journalist
ein ehemaliger zeitungsredakteur dem ich
der christlichen stimme so heißt die
zeitung jetzt meine frage
warum spendiert du deinen hauptfiguren
nicht nur einen ehrbaren beruf
also was solides
naja natürlich hängt das sind meine
eigenen
mit einem eigenen
balancieren zwischen realität und
fiktion zusammen und in dem fall aber
bei dem
erzähler in diesem roman war es einfach
so dass mich dieser
hintergrund sehr interessiert hat es er
sagt über sich selbst bei dieser zeitung
wir waren zwei halb studierte männer und
vier aus studierte frauen ja und die
haben diese zeitung sozusagen zugrunde
geschrieben und mich hat das
interessiert
als hintergrund und der macht ja jetzt
was ganz anderes er schreibt nämlich
kleine geschichten für schlaflose für
eine radio nach zündung ja und das ist
sein job um sich über wasser zu halten
aber ich glaube dass ich selbst jemand
bin der
alles mögliche in seinem leben schon
gemacht hat um irgendwie nicht über
wasser ist falsch aber um einfach das
geld zu verdienen was nun zu dienen muss
und
das ist immer ein balance-akt und
insofern wäre mir jetzt eine figur die
einfach das geld hat die würde mich
glaube ich nicht so interessieren
ja geld verdienen
du verdienst ein dank gilt ja unter
anderem damit dass du
so was geworden bist wie ein spezialist
für vertrackte
liebesgeschichten also diesen begriff
oder einen ähnlichen wurf habe ich
bestimmt schon 100 mal gelesen und jedes
mal wenn ich das gelesen habt vertrackte
liebesgeschichten habe ich mich gefragt
ja gibt's denn eigentlich andere
das ist gut gibt es denn einfache
liebesgeschichten wenn es sie gibt warum
werden sie nicht erzählt weil sie weil
sie langweilig sind auch die wurden
schon von einzelnen erzählt ich will
jetzt keine beispiele nennen was sie
haben mich in der tat tödlich
gelangweilt ja
also ein zentrales thema haben wir schon
angesprochen die vertrackte
liebesgeschichte
das ist meine frau
wir haben zeit
es war bestimmt es war bestimmt wichtig
jetzt waren wir bei den
libeskind ja aber es geht ja nicht nur
um die liebe und die liebe herum gibt es
ja immer noch ganz ganz viele andere
dinge und und alles was passiert hat ja
irgendwie dann auch mit der
dem geliebten menschen mit den
verhältnissen mit der eigenen
wahrnehmung empfindung zu tun und in
diesem moment
geht es jetzt zunächst einmal unter
anderem unter anderem kommen noch auf
das eine oder andere wo zunächst einmal
geht es ja darum sich ein bild zu machen
ganz buchstäblich zu fotografieren einen
menschen zu fotografieren sich ein
bildes sogar sagen mit dem handy
mit dem aller welt gerät das wort handy
wird ja mit der vermieden in dem roman
ja aber es geht auch noch um sich ein
bild machen übertragenen sinn ein bild
machen vom fremden ein bild von einem
anderen von gegenüber
es geht auch um selbst bilder vor allem
das selbstbild des männlichen
protagonisten ich erzählers der also
sehr viel über sich nachdenken
das tun ja seine
protagonisten eigentlich
immer sie erforschen sich unentwegt
und ich bin eigentlich immer sehr im
zweifel ob sie sich auf die schliche
kommen aber das können wir mal offen
lassen bleiben wir noch einen moment bei
den bei den bildern also in diesem roman
ist es so der ich-erzähler fährt durch
italien
und erfährt auf einer route die er zehn
jahre zuvor schon mal befahren hat und
zwar mit seiner damaligen
lebensgefährtin lydia
die ist passé die hat jetzt einen
anderen der spielt auch eine rolle ein
herr cordes wichtige rolle zudem kommen
wir später also der ich-erzähler ist
unterwegs auf dieser route
und will sich gewissermaßen erinnern an
das was war damals war und auch
natürlich
nach möglichkeit eine antwort auf die
frage bekommen
wieso ist die situation heute so wie sie
ist sie ist mit herrn cordes zusammen er
ist allein
er will die alten orte noch einmal
abfahren und dann trifft er aber
eine junge frau und wenn diese junge
frau stichwort mach dir ein bild wenn
diese frau
fotografiert wird passiert etwas
seltsames und was dann passiert das
werden wir zu hören
ja schönen guten tag
guten namen vielmehr auch die die uns
von entfernteren orten zu schauen ich
freue mich dass ich hier sein kann und
ich lese jetzt zunächst mal die ersten
seiten des romans das fängt an mit einem
mit einem satz an den sich eine ganze
seite anschluss und ich habe es aber
dann nach 300 mal schreiben dieser seite
geschafft das alles zu streichen bis auf
diesen satz und der steht hier isoliert
das ist der beginn
danach habe ich so angefangen wie das
zweite kapitel anfängen der folgende
bericht zu treuen händen wissen das wird
sich zeigen
geht auf etwas zurück das eigentlich
nicht sein kann und doch der fall war zu
verstehen höchstens durch zuneigung wie
alles uns fremde
das erste in einer kanadischen
tageszeitung
gazzetta dell sud aufgetauchte falsche
und zugleich richtige bild der person
die mir trotz aller zuneigung und
wahrscheinlich auch liebe bis zuletzt
fremd war zeigt bei nur flüchtigem
hinsehen kaum mehr als einen streifen
buschland unter blankem himmel allein
der hauch eines wolkenband schwebt über
dornigen baum kohlen am horizont
sieht man aber genauer hin erkennt man
etwas im fern zum sandigen vordergrund
eine weibliche gestalt mit zwei
kanistern in einer vorwärtsbewegung
einer ihrer füße ist aufgesetzt der
andere bereit für den nächsten schritt
sie trägt ein rotes kittelkleid und
wirft einen kurzen schatten in
gehrichtung die kanister jemals in einer
hand die pendel stellung gegenläufig
beugen durch ihr gewicht den an sich
langen körper seinem schatten entgegen
nur der kopf ist aufgerichtet das
gesicht dabei wie verdunkelt vor sonne
das ganze könnte die vorlage für ein
plakat über mühsames wasserholen durch
frauen nach einem zu trockenen
afrikanischen ort sein und damit wäre
über das bild schon alles gesagt hätte
es jemand in dieser umgebung aufgenommen
angeblich soll es erst einen tag vor
erscheinen der genannten zeitung in den
julischen küstenort milito die porto
cervo entstanden sein ecke via ein rico
berlingo wie madonna zwar mit einem
stillgelegten karussell auf leeren
grundstück und auf einem der wie
galoppieren den pferdchen soll laut
einem anwohner eine junge hochgewachsene
von dunkler haut oder susanne donner
alter dalla palace cura gesessen haben
und das sogar übermütig so der zeuge der
sein aller welt gerät gezückt hatte um
den tatbestand im bild festzuhalten
dabei herausgekommen sei jedoch das
gänzlich andere afrikanische motiv was
man nur glauben oder nicht glauben kann
als durchaus menschen möglich erschien
es mir allerdings dass ich eine junge
frau auf ihrer suche nach einem besseren
leben oder dem glück aus purem übermut
auf eine attraktion dieser art am
wegrand setzt
neben dem buschland bild mit einer
wasser trägerin im hintergrund gab es
doch ein zweites foto auf der frontseite
der zeitung einst das später die polizei
von dem karussell gemacht hat freilich
ohne die illegale wie sie offiziell ließ
die hochgewachsene fremde die der
anwohner gesehen und fotografiert haben
will nur dass jenes so andere bild
zurück blieb das karussell auf dem
polizeifoto war ein kläglichen zustand
einen ebenso kläglichen eindruck machte
die straße dahinter deutlich zu sehen am
linken oberen bildrand das schild mit
dem namen des tages lag in deren
generalsekretärs der kommunistischen
partei eines landes dachte ich dass er
wohl kaum wiedererkennen würde keine 40
jahre nach dessen tod das unstrittige
von der polizei gemachte foto war so ein
bild des jammers wäre das andere solche
rätsel aufgab das ist der anwohner und
besitzer des grundstücks mit dem
karussell darauf an der leiter an den
leiter der örtlichen carabinieri
geschickt hat von lois seinen weg in die
gazzetta der süd nahm und damit zu mir
wenige schritte unterhalb des lungomare
von radio mit blick auf sizilien an
einem der glühendsten tage des
diesjährigen sommers der bekanntlich
alle hitzerekorde in den schatten
gestellt hat
all das wird die erste zumutung jetzt
all das war vor zwei monaten
mitte august
genauer kurz nach mariä himmelfahrt oder
ferragosto wie dieser tag dort heißt und
auch mein kauf der zeitung hätte etwas
mit der hitze zu tun er geschah aus
auflehnung gegen die eigene agonie eben
eine zeitung in händen zu halten und
wenigstens die mit unterschriften in
fremder sprache zu erfassen einer
sprache in der ich einiges verstehen
leider wenig zu sagen imstande bin die
ich aber ihrem ton nach im ganzen liebe
und das hat dazu geführt mich auch in
den artikeln zu den zwei bildern etwas
einzulesen und zwar im halbschatten
einer zerzausten palme vor einer
badeanstalt der heruntergekommen ssten
die man sich nur vorstellen kann auf
fast jeder der ausgebleichten
kabinentüren gab es die immer gleiche
botschaft in form einer kritzelei das
vor man gelegentlich abstehende samt
gestrichener fontänen hier nur deshalb
erwähnt weil vor gut zehn jahren die
kabinentüren damals noch in unschuldigem
weiß die für den menschen meines lebens
gehaltene frau auf den stufen zu einer
der kabinen gesessen hatte in einem
schulterfreien kleid obwohl es kühl
gewesen waren dem tag bloß ihr nicht sie
hat mich vor einigen monaten verlassen
und der grund für eine zugreise bis zu
meerenge zwischen region messina ist für
nüchtern denkende wohl kaum verständlich
damals hatten wir kalabrien als
verliebte bereits per mietwagen mit
einem anderen paar und die neuerliche
reise sollte dazu dienen den anhalten
den schmerz des verlassenen durch einen
noch engeren
aktuelleren schmerz den des wiedersehens
mit den orten des anfänglichen glückes
zu beenden
sicher keine methode die psychologen
empfehlen würden eher schon einem
glauben verbundene mit sich selbst auf
kriegsfuß stehende leute die mir näher
sind ich war um das hier gleich zu sagen
viele jahre bei einer entsprechenden
zeitung der christlichen stimme mit
meinen immer weltlichen beiträgen einer
der totengräber des blattes glauben ist
glaubenssache und denn es eine seele
gibt ist sie nicht von dieser welt in
die welt gesetzt aber haben wir
redakteure das gegenteil als herrenlose
propheten die reise durch galati mit dem
andern paar hatte im mai stattgefunden
weil wie gesagt auf kühlem wetter aber
was spielt das für eine rolle wenn zwei
das gefühl haben ihr wunderbares
gemeinsames leben würde damit beginnen
nein er hat eine rolle gespielt dass es
eine autoreise mit einem neurologen am
steuer war in dem keller des gehirns der
meinte die liebe sei höchstens doch
dingfest zu machen abends beim wein und
er war auch war ein kenner zudem im
leben der bienen zu hause hielt der
ineinander verschränkte vorträge über
das gehirn und die gewohnheiten der
bienen sowie den anbau von wein vorträge
die anderen tax im auto weiter gegen ein
sanft korrigiert von seiner frau einer
professorin oft im bieter kleinsten
teilchen dazu an kultur jeder art
interessiert jeder
aber nun also wieder kalabrien auch
wieder ein mietwagen sowie kleiner und
die jetzt geplante fahrt in glühender
hitze noch hatte ich den wagen nicht
abgeholt und bin mit der kassette sud in
der hand sozusagen frei am lungomare
entlang gelaufen wo hinter der alten
badeanstalt tagsüber ein riesenrad
reglos in der sonne stand während ein
paar schritte weiter vor dem museum für
altertümer so gut wie reglose afrikaner
flaschen mit eis gekühlt im wasser
anboten ich hatte eine der kleinen
flaschen gekauft wurde im besuch des
museums in dem ich die beiden vorräte im
flachen meer entdeckte und durch den
sandigen grund bestens erhaltenen bronze
krieger noch einmal lange betrachtet
habe wie damals mit meiner neuen liebe
sie als physiotherapeutin mit besonderem
interesse für die so sichtbare aber nach
ihrem dafürhalten entspannte muskulatur
der beiden krieger die flasche war schon
halb getrunken als ich nach dem
aufenthalt im museum den artikel zu den
fotos auf der frontseite der zeitung
doch im ganzen zu lesen versuchte und so
allmählich erfasste was dort stand eben
dass jenes foto einer wasser trägerin im
buschland völlig unerklärlich sei aber
der namentlich genannte anwohner der die
hochgewachsene fremde auf dem karussell
wrack aufgenommen hatte als verdienter
mitbürger
conchita dino patti wolle über jeden
verdacht eines tricks betrug stehe um
sich damit interessant zu machen wie es
dort hieß es war ein langsames lesen mit
hilfe des wörterbuchs und am ende war
die flasche leer
und ich kaufte bei den reglosen
afrikanern eine neue um sie mit genuss
auf dem nunmehr in betrieb genommenen
riesenrad zu trinken den blick dabei auf
sizilien gerichtet auf den schon seit
tagen wieder einmal glut verschleudern
denn etwa aus der ferne gesehen in
striche fontänen wie die auf der
badeanstalt nur viel größer und viel
schöner
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
das ist sozusagen die overtüre
und
dieser ich erzähler der namenlos ist
und der mit mir
nicht sehr viel gemein hat also
jedenfalls weniger als manche denken
dieser ich-erzähler namenlos der macht
sich auf die suche nach dieser
rätselhaften frau warum weil sie für ihn
natürlich das ideale objekt ist um eine
seiner guten 8 seiner geschichten für
schlaflose zu schreiben von denen er
zurzeit lebt
ich will das jetzt nur ganz kurz
zusammenfassen es gelingt ihm auch er
trifft diesen mann der dieses foto
gemacht hat der gibt ihm einige tipps
und erfährt herum und nach tagen schafft
er es tatsächlich ihr zu begegnen das
heißt sie sagt dann nicht er hätte sie
gesucht sondern sie ihn da überrascht
dass sie als er die haube als sie die
haube seines mietwagens mit dem ärmel
reinigt er nimmt sie dann mit das heißt
sie fragt ihn ein anders sie fragt ihn
ob er sie nach rom fahren könnte und
natürlich hat er das gar nicht vor
sondern er will ja seine
erinnerungsreise machen er sagt aber ja
gut ich fahre dich nach oben oder fahre
sie nach oben sie spricht sehr gut
englisch und
setzt aber ganz stur seine
erinnerungsreise fort und sagt ihr das
sei besser so wenn man auf kleinen
nebenstraßen fahren würde denn
inzwischen ist sie bereits bekannt in
der zeitung wird über sie berichtet
sogar im lokalfernsehen und er sagt
besser wir meiden die autobahn da gibts
nur videoüberwachung wir fahren also auf
kleinen nebenstraßen
und ich lese ihnen jetzt eine längere
passage da sind sie schon mehrere tage
unterwegs und er hat für sie etwas
glaube ich zum anziehen gekauft und
jetzt muss ich ganz kurz nach gucken das
ist auf seite
93 ja
die afrikanerin erleben sie er weiß ihre
namen das sage ich jetzt hier aus
information er weiß ihre namen aber
dieser name ist so melodiös und so
bestechend dass er ihn in seinem bericht
nicht verwendet weil er denkt wenn er
das tun würde dann würde das so aussehen
als wollte er für sie stimmung machen
und dass er will er vermeiden er will er
will das so
sachlich wie möglich erzählen was
natürlich muss links die afrikanerin
hatte wie schlafend noch in sich ein
gefaltet man muss dazu sagen dass sie
sehr groß ist meine kappe halb auf dem
kopf in dem kleinen fiat gesessen als
ich nicht mit den von ihr beschriebenen
sache nicht ganz der gewünschten version
von dem recht bescheiden markt in longo
buckow zurückkam zwar hatte ich ein
großes tuch bekommen aber nicht
dunkelblaue dafür in not an dem herbst
droht dazu eine gebrauchte denn im
jacket fast in meiner größe sowie eine
mit sicherheit falsche tom ford
sonnenbrille und ich hatte auch noch
eine kappe mit ferrari emblem kaufen
können wollt ihr aber die rom kappe mit
der koloss ihrem silhouette überlassen
ich sag dir die käufe und sie schnell
die nicht etwa aus dem sitzt sondern
schob nur die kappe so weit zurück dass
sie sehen konnte was sie hingegen nahm
die jacke schiene zu gefallen so wie sie
über den kragen strich auf das tuch war
von der größe und dem stoff in ihrem
sinne anders die sonnenbrille sie hat
die mir meine zurückgegeben ja sogar
aufgesetzt als sich beide hände zum
auspacken braucht zum ausparken brauchte
und etwas später als wir schon auf der
straße hinter dem kleinen berg dort
waren die tom ford brille zunächst
inspiziert und gleich als falsch erkannt
um dann im rückspiegel kurz auf die
fahrerseite gebeugt zu sehen ob sie ihr
steht kommentiert mit nur einem wort aus
der eigenen sprache
das klang so eine sonnenbrille zwar bloß
keine für mich schließlich sagte sie
aber senk ju zwei finger dabei an die
schläfe gelegt und aus dieser gestern
raus machte sie anstalten medi kappe
zurückzugeben und ich sagte nur keep it
einfach weil ich sie sehen wollte mit
dieser kappe die mir lydia nachts lydia
ist die physiotherapeutin die mir lydia
nachts in einem römischen kiosk gekauft
hatte aus einer laune heraus nach dem
besuch unseres lieblings lokals der
osteria in china am borghese park wir
waren betrunken sie mehr als ich und sie
sah diese kappe und sagte du musst die
tragen die erinnert an den ort an dem
die christen wilden tieren vorgeworfen
wurden weil sie nicht bereit waren von
ihrem glauben zu lassen in der redaktion
musst du sie tragen als mahnung für die
schlafen und wenn du mit mir ins bett
gehst als versteck für dein graues haar
tust du das zwei- dreimal hat sie das
gerufen tust du das und ist dabei um
mich herum getanzt lydia wurde zum kind
wenn sie betrunken war einem lachenden
etwas boshaften mädchen das monolithen
konnte oder die finger von ihm lassen
und dann hat sie die colosseum kappe
gekauft und mir aufgesetzt frech nach
hinten gerückt als offenes visier wie
die afrikanerin sie trug als wir wieder
durch eine berglandschaft fuhren als
einzige weit und breit es war ein fahren
ohne ziel was die kommende nacht
betrafen so ging es zunächst weiter als
gäbe ist ein ziel über die kleinen
ortschaften coppola die und kalou die
und den größeren flecken rossano schon
wieder nahe am meer von dort allerdings
erneut in richtung des wiler gebirges
mit einer kehre von der echa nahm eine
mitreißende hätte sie gar nicht bemerkt
wir sind den kalabrien wohl gemerkt
hätte sie gar nicht bemerkt sie sagt und
bewegt da die arme um die knie gezwungen
aber etwa auf halber strecke zu dem nest
san demetrio ich hatte noch einmal kurz
die um mich rückzuversichern in die
karte gesehen auf einer kurvigen straße
mit immer wieder anderem und bald schon
niedrigem sonneneinfall machte sie auf
einmal zeichen dass ich halten sollte
ich nahm an ihm sei übel von der pfarrei
und hielt in einer kurve mit größerer
wucht und sich augenblicklich aus und
liefern den rand einer steilwand den
makler aber sie übergab sich nicht etwas
ich stand dort nur die falsche komforth
brille in der hand und schaute ruhig zum
wagen bis sich ebenfalls ausstieg bei
mir die karte wir werden wieder dorthin
fahren wo wir hergekommen sein rief sie
klappt und nur halblaut hatte sie dieses
sei zugerufen mir kaum als frage eher
als antwort seit zwei tagen fahren wir
durch die gegend wie es dir gefällt
dabei ich muss nach rom meinen cousin
dort finden sonst wenig verloren einzig
ihre augen sagt mir das so nach einem
blick in die karte wusste ich dass wir
gar nicht auf der strecke nach san
demetrio rahn weil sie ohne kurven
eingezeichnet war ich also irgendwo
falsch abgebogen sein musste sie
wiederholte er war fast leise jetzt eine
hand in die teil die gestemmt und da ist
es passiert was ich bisher vermieden
hatte aus ihrem warum das nur eine
umständliche strecke betrag wurde mein
warum im hinblick auf alles was sie wahr
oder nicht wahr warum gibt es kein bild
von dir wie kann es sein dass man dich
aufnimmt und etwas anderes herauskommt
sagt mir dass und stehen nicht da als
wäre an alldem nichts dran und wer bist
du wenn das ganze kein trick ist und
auch kein wunder wenn es zu dir gehört
falls du über weiß das ist zu dir gehört
vor zwei tagen in dem verlassenen ort
hättest du auch einfach verschwinden
könnten bist aber zum einzigen auto
gegangen dass auf dem parkplatz stand
und hass im staub von der habe gibt und
er habe gewischt warum und warum glaubst
du nehme ich dich mit weil ich mit ihr
ins bett wenn ich denke nicht dass ich
das will es würde nichts besser machen
das zu wollen weder für mich noch für
dich ich bin bloß den fahrer nichts
weiter
das hatte ich tatsächlich gesagt alles
andere er vor mich hin gedacht und auch
das eine oder andere vor mich hin
gesprochen ich erinnere mich noch genau
an die letzten worte ein just your drive
mit ihren ton mit einiger schärfe und
dass sie daraufhin etwas in ihrer
sprache gesagt hat beängstigend leise
und gleichzeitig die sonnenbrille in der
verbundenen hand sie hat eine verletzung
zerbrach das es knackte wie bei einem
tisch dem mann zutritt und dass sie mir
die teile der brille auf dem handteller
zeigte die gebrochenen bügel die kaputte
gläser sie kamen dabei auf mich zu mit
etwas in den augen wie triumph und
bewegte die hand dass die teile
herausziehen gefasst wo die füße ein wie
ein see her das passiert mit dingen die
ich nicht will und es könnte auch mit
dir passieren sie war stehengeblieben
den kopf leicht im nacken was ihr noch
etwas größer machte und ich sagte sie
sollten mir vertrauen ich hätte nur
eines vor sie sicher an ihr ziel zu
bringen nach oben unterwegs würden wir
eine neue sonnenbrille kaufen eine die
zu ihr passe ja ich hatte wirklich
geglaubt es sei bei dem ganzen um die
brille gegangen die wir gern daran
glauben dass nur etwas sichtbares schuld
an dem sein könnte was wir nicht
verstehen erst als sie anfing sich an
der hand mit der sie das gestell und die
gläser zerdrückt hat den schamlosen
verband abzunehmen mit ruhigem blick zu
mir ein sie dir auch das an das passiert
wenn man helfen will aber das falsche
macht ist mir aufgegangen dass ihre
größe einen nicht sichtbaren teil hatte
wie verdeckt von den langen beinen und
armen ihrem schlanken hals und kopf sie
warf den verband zu den brillen teilen
dann nahm sie mir die karte aus den
händen und stieg in den wagen und kaum
saß ich
darf sich eben doch als er fahrer wieder
als ihr fahrer hinter dem steuer da
tippte sie an die karte die gegen denn
der wir ungefähr sagt waren und sagte
lowe machte dabei aber zeichen dass es
in der eingeschlagenen richtung
weitergehen sollte obwohl wir ja vorher
falsch abgebogen waren also blieb ich
auf dem gewundenen berg sträßchen ohne
zu wissen wohin und auch ohne zu wissen
wer damit mir fuhr ich wusste nur eines
wenn wissen hier der richtige ausdruck
ist er war es einer fassen wie man im
dunkeln etwas erfasst eine tischkante
dass ich ihre gegenwart mehr brauchte
als sie die meine und nach erreichen des
hochtals eingeschlossen von calenberg
rücken kamen wir über eine weitere
abzweigung am ende doch noch nach san
demetrio bestehen des kleinen und
kleinsten häusern zusammen geschafft wie
ein ängstliches rudel und am rande
dieses von keinerlei erinnerungen an die
damaligen reise belasteten fleckens
wichtig bei einer kaffeebar in einem
fast frei stehenden würfelförmigen haus
dem fenster neben der bar tür ein schild
kamera ruhms es war wie ein wink und ich
wollte die lage klären was für leute in
der basis und ob zwei zimmer frei wären
endlich wieder ein bett und eine dusche
für sie und für mich sagte ich bettin
schauer für juni eine emphase die dazu
geführt hat dass die afrikanerin mich
ansah wie dem ich bis zu dem zeitpunkt
noch nicht angesehen hatte als mann um
den achseln zucken zusagen für mein
gefühl achselzucken sie hat sich gar
nicht bewegt nur die braunen etwas
zusammen gezogen dass ein zimmer reichen
würde und mit diesem freibrief oder was
es war bin ich ausgestiegen und die paar
schritte zu dem möglichen quartier
gegangen
in der offenen tür zu der baring ein
vorhang aus bunten plastik streifen mit
lücken dazwischen ich musste gar nicht
eintreten um zu sehen dass an den drei
vier kleinen tisch niemand saß und nur
ein junger mann mit zopf allein hinter
dem tresen stand
und dort hat er nichts weiter als ein
bild nach dem angriff von sich zu machen
es war ein geschehen bei dem man nicht
stören wollte also sah ich ihn zu wer
jedes bild wieder löschte um sofort das
nächste zu machen als wäre dass alfie
zugleich beweis und gegenbeweis für die
erkenntnis lücke die kant aufgezeigt hat
was wir an sich sind bleibt für uns
unerkennbar ein ewiges fehlen mit dem
man auch ewiges sehnen einhergeht
folglich strecke wir immer wieder den
arm für ein neues bild das auch wieder
nur zeigt wege für einen augenblick
waren und nicht wer wir sind und genau
das hätte cannes triumphieren den dürren
zeigefinger heben lassen
es denn aber immer neue bilder sein
müssen dann ist damit doch bewiesen dass
ich das was wir an sich sind weder
gedanklich erfassen lässt noch in ein
abbild unseres unbedeutenden äußeren
zwingen
ich weiß nicht ob er das vor betreten
der bar auch nur ungefähr so durch den
kopf gegangen ist wie er in erinnerung
an diese szene ich weiß nur wie sehr
nicht die beschäftigung des jungen
mannes im bann gehalten hat und dass ich
an cannes denken musste und wie ich noch
in diesem band war es die afrikanerin
dazu getreten erst bemerkt dass sie
neben gestärkt sie verfolgte was ich
verfolgte zwei finger an die lippen
finger der hand mit derartigen wunde die
aufgegangen war und blutete ein für mich
lichter moment
und im nächsten moment war schon der
streifen vor auseinander geschoben und
ich betrag die bar und der junge mann
legte das gerät das sie nicht weiter
gebracht hatte auf den tresen als hätte
ich mir alles vorherige nur eingebildet
mitte zwanzig mochte deren sich fern
achte gewesen sein und hätte ihn das
plötzliche auftauchen eines zeugen und
einer zeuge nicht etwas erhöhten lassen
wäre ich vielleicht ohne die gewünschten
auskünfte niedergegangen so aber erfuhr
ich dass es zwar zwei zimmer über der
bar gab was dem plural auf dem schild
kamera wunsch entsprach aber nur eines
mit bad und einen balkon das haben wir
genommen und wenn ich mir sage denke ich
an einen seitenblick der afrikanerin die
es mir leicht gemacht hat sehr leicht
sogar
die demat upton gegenüber in der aller
welt sprache meine frau zu nennen
und für uns beide dass eine bessere
zimmer zu wählen leicht in dem moment
während es schon kurz danach als sich
bei dem jungen mann mit zopf noch bier
und chips kaufte und einen espresso
bestellte um ihn an einem der tische
langsam zu trinken damit meine
begleiterin in ruhe duschen konnte etwas
von einer unlösbaren aufgabe hatte als
paar in dem zimmer unter gekommen zu
sein
das heißt nichts war mehr leicht was sie
und mich betraf oder anders gesagt
höchstens blicke in landschaften sind
harmlos blicke auf bilder könnte es
schon
in sich haben und seitenblicke wie der
der mir gegolten hat sind berührungen
ohne dass eine haut an die andere gerät
nur stellt sie einen vor dasselbe
problem wie die berührung reagieren zu
müssen als wäre man etwa gestreichelt
worden ein erwidere meinen blick lass
mich dich sehen damit wir beide nicht
mehr im dunkeln tappen der blick
unerschöpfliches roman material das
paradies und die hölle auf kurze distanz
nach dem espresso und noch ein paar
schritten im freien hatte ich an unsere
zimmertür geklopft so wie es sein sollte
wenn man sich nicht kennt und bin erst
auf ihr jetzt eingetreten und da sie auf
dem bett um sich ein handtuch mit
peanuts figuren das gehörte zur
ausstattung im bad in ein zweites sie
war mit ihrem verletzten hand
beschäftigt dass die loch artige wunde
zwischen den knöcheln mit
toilettenpapier abzutupfen zwischendurch
sah sie mich an wieder mit dem blick der
einen vor probleme stellt das wasser in
der dusche werde nicht richtig waren
sagte sie als wären wir schon eine ganze
weile auf reisen und jede nacht in einem
anderen zimmer mal mit guter mal mit
weniger guter dusche warmes wasser
darauf kam es im moment nicht an ich
wollte mir nur den schweiß ab waschen
nachdem das getan war sah ich dass sie
unsere restlichen lebensmittel auf einem
weißen plastiktisch der auf dem balkon
stand ausgebreitet hatte und stellte das
bier und die chips dazu ready for dinner
sagte ich und alles erschien plötzlich
so einfach wie diese aufforderung zum
abendessen ja ich erinnere mich als es
als es mir als film vorgestellt zu haben
zwei die einander völlig fremd sind der
eine mit kleinem mietwagen und etwas
geld unterwegs um sich eine frau ist dem
kopf zu schlagen die ihn verlassen hat
sich die geschichte mit ihr so zu
erzählen dass er gut aus ihr heraus
kommt und der andere oder die andere wie
es heißen muss nun mit sich selbst
unterwegs um ihr glück zu finden eine
besseres leben zu kommen oder überhaupt
ans leben aber dieser film hat auf dem
balkon mit sicht auf das sila gebirge im
abendlicht geändert wir beide aufknacken
den plastik hockern die zu dem tisch
gehört die afrikanerin immer noch in das
peanuts tuch gehüllt tank das dosenbier
wie eine verdurstende sie nahm sich auch
von den chips bis die tüte leer war ab
und zu sei sie zu mir rüber als wäre ich
noch fremder für sie als andersherum es
war nicht leicht
ihren langen beinen unter den tisch
auszuweichen es war auch nicht leicht
ihr still sein zu ertragen sie nur essen
und trinken zu sehen bis sie ich weiß
nicht warum wie aus dem nichts heraus
nach meiner arbeit fragte wovon ich
leben würde und ob das eine arbeit sei
die mich glücklich machen tell me hat
sie leise gesagt und überhaupt sprach
sie fast nur leise wie mit gestauchte
schon häufig zum schweigen gebracht der
stimme you happy with you work eine
frage mit blick zu dem gebirge wird
durch ihr profil zu sehen war scharf
abgesetzt gegen den abendhimmel und in
dem moment wie ein beweis dass der
mensch kein zufall ist sondern schöpfung
eine unfassbar gute idee aber
wenn ich an diese stunde im abnehmenden
lichts zurückdenke ist auch der gedanke
an eine falsche antwort dass sich für
einen radiosender arbeiten würde und
main gebiet die glaubens angelegenheiten
sein das heißt ich nannte eine arbeit
die es lange gegeben hatte und seitdem
aus der zeitungen keiner weise mehr gab
die ich nur während des redens darüber
noch einmal heraufbeschwor indem ich von
reisen zu zentren des glaubens sprach
und von dort zu berichten romancier
jerusalem bis meine zuhörerin nach einer
pause in der ich sie nichts das
angesehen hatte ihr bei allem dunkle im
grunde helles gesicht wissen wollte was
mit mir sei statt etwa zu fragen wie es
um meinen glauben steht als besucher
solcher orte woran ich denken würde wenn
ich sie ansehen es war die frage
die auf eine parkbank oder nein war
gehört eine der fragen von ersten abend
denn die man zusammen verbringt
vielleicht auch der erst nachts was
denkst du wenn du mich ansiehst wer bin
ich für dich und wer bist du wenn du
meinst mich zu sehen wie ich bin woran
ich denke daran dass wir alle aus deinem
kontinent ab stammen von einer kleinen
eine gruppe die ihn vor 60.000 jahren
verlassen hat um sich über die ganze
welt auszubreiten sagte ich was an sich
sogar richtig war meines wissens
zutreffend aber als antwort wieder
falsch weil es mehr erst nach der frage
durch den kopf gegangen ist während ich
vorher als ich sie angesehen habe an gar
nichts dachte noch etwas empfand für
dass es höchstens im nachhinein worte
gibt aber dann solche die man nicht
sagen möchte aus schlagern aus filmen
der werbung schau mich bitte nicht zu
ahnen die verdammt schön du bist dein
mund gehört verboten und so weiter aber
davon nichts
nichts stattdessen dieser abstammung
sache wir heutigen als nachfahren von
nur ein paar hundert kühnen klein
dunkelhäutig vermutlich beharrt aber mit
dem genom dass wir noch in uns tragen
menschen die auf lebenslang im weg ihre
wege verlassen haben um die welt zu
erobern und die afrikanerin sagte mit
etwas verspätung dazu unsere bierdosen
gegeneinander stossend ob ich jetzt
vergeben würde wir seien verwandte
das seien wir nicht
oder glaubte dass sie mir glauben würde
ich hätte an die verarbeitungs
geschichte der menschheit gedacht als
ich sie ansah
judith sagte sie ihm auch stehen bereit
sich schon schlafen zu legen dabei um
den mund einen ausdruck wie manchmal die
zwei frauen im redaktions kreis der
zeitung die von männlicher seite in bunt
und boden geschrieben wurde nahe ermüden
lächeln wenn einer der zwei halb
studierten wieder einer mit einem
beitrag die welt und gleich auch noch
das leben im ganzen erklärt hatte beide
frauen dagegen promovierte theologin die
eine die andere aus dem therapie milieu
hatten präzise kleinarbeit geleistet
während wir bei jeder gelegenheit
fundamentales zum besten gaben ja uns
einmal sogar aus anlass der weltweiten
bewegung für maßnahmen gegen die
erderwärmung zu einem beitrag
zusammengetan haben einer gemeinsamen
erklärung der welt zur verbesserung
derselben sowie zu ihrer zeit schelling
kegel und hölderlin gemeinsam ein
grundsatzprogramm des idealismus
verfasst hatten mit folgendem größenwahn
schluss uns von den frauen mit eben
diesem lächeln unter die nase gerieben
ein höherer geist vom himmel gesamt muss
diese neue religion unter uns stiften
sie wird das letzte größte werk der
menschheit sein zitat ende
[Applaus]
ja vielen dank das waren nur ein paar
seiten
und da steckt so wahnsinnig viel drin
dass ich jetzt gar nicht so recht weiß
wo ich anfangen soll
was mir aufgefallen ist
relativ früh also für meine verhältnisse
früher das heißt nach 300 seiten etwa
dass viele dinge beim ersten mal
eigentlich klar ausgesprochen werden
offen zu tage liegen kann man versteht
sie nicht und versteht die bedeutung
nicht die bedeutung zeigt sich erst viel
später und das ist mit ganz vielen
sachen so das fängt wir haben gehört der
erste satz da verfällt das wort bericht
es dauert sehr lange bis wir dann
erfahren
um was für eine art von bericht ist sich
eigentlich handelt und wenn wir das
erfahren stellt sich im selben moment
die frage ist das eigentlich die
richtige bezeichnung bericht könnte es
nicht auch
heißen geständnis oder beichte
anderes beispiel
eine halbe seite denn wenn bodo
kirchhoff jetzt eine halbe seite weiter
gelesen hätte dann hätte er ein kleines
feuerzeug aus dem besitz der
afrikanerinnen genommen und das
nächtliche zimmer
erhält und dann wieder was gedacht und
irgendwann das fahrzeug ausgemacht hätte
er auch geschlafen paar hundert seiten
später taucht dieses fahrzeug ganz
woanders im ganz anderen zusammenhang
wieder auf und uns so passiert ist
eigentlich ständig also dieser roman
geschrieben mit einer unglaublichen
sorgfalt
und genauigkeit
kleinsten dingen gegenüber und einer
fast ebenso großen lässigkeit mit dem
die ganz offen liegenden großen fragen
ausgespart werden was meine ich damit
naja die afrikanerin wie kann denn das
sein
die fotos werden aufgenommen
und zeigen etwas ganz anderes zeigen
nicht sie aber etwas was mit ihrem leben
zu tun hat
der ich-erzähler denkt drüber nach
aber
er denkt sogar daran sie zu fragen aber
er tut es nicht stattdessen zitiert
erkannt und regt sich darüber auf dass
der bahrainer sitzt und einzel wie von
sich macht
eins nach dem anderen die fragen die
gestellt werden die werden nicht
ausgesprochen die denkt er nur
aber die fragen die gestellt werden
könnte man teilweise zumindest
auch einfach umdrehen wir haben eine
gehört seit 95 das ist dieser monolog wo
er überlegt was er eigentlich jetzt
sagen müsste was er sie alles fragen
will da heißt es und wer bist du wenn
das ganze kein trick ist und auch kein
wunder wenn es zu dir gehört die frage
könnte man auch umdrehen wer bist du
wenn es ein wunder ist denn religion
spielt hier eine ganz große rolle
aber sie tut das auf eine unauffällige
weise immer es ist andere als natürlich
so offensichtlich christliche stimme es
ist immer vom glauben die frage glaubst
du was glaubst du
das wird noch viele viele weitere motive
aus diesem feld geben aber bleiben wir
mal bei diesem wer bist du wenn es ein
wunder ist da habe ich mich gefragt und
dieser stelle zum ersten mal also
natürlich nicht was ist das für eine
frau eine junge afrikanerin haben wir
gehört eine illegale haben wir gehört
also ist geflohen
wir wissen zu diesem zeitpunkt glaube
ich auch schon dass sie in libyen war in
einem lager sie hat eine verletzung an
der hand
ein loch in der hand ist das ein grund
mal
wieso versagt die digitale technik vor
ihrer erscheinung wieso ist sie nicht im
bilde zu bangen
und da habe ich mich gefragt ist
das auch ein bisschen eine eine moderne
heiligenfigur
die aber niemand so wahrnehmen würde der
erzähler nicht und der rest der welt
auch nicht
also ich glaube dass
sicher da kann etwas dran sein aber
für mich ist folgendes entscheidend
dass
das digitale oder sagen wir mal dass
dass es scheitert ihr
ihr gesicht in nullen und einsen zu
transformieren und dann wieder in pixel
und bilder dass das scheitert
das ist für mich
das
das ist sozusagen eine gegenbewegung zu
dem triumph zu dem ihm an enten triumph
des digitalen zeitalters die
transzendenz endgültig besiegt zu haben
und aus der welt geschafft zu haben und
das ist etwas was mich seit vielen seit
langem beschäftigt
und
wenn man jetzt an wenn ich jetzt
angefangen hätte ich habe mir das ja
auch lange überlegt dieser sache
sozusagen irgendwie physikalisch oder
sonstwie nachzugehen ich habe ja nur
folgendes gemacht ich habe manchmal eine
zeitung zitiert die experten dann
irgendwie zu wort hat kommen lassen ja
die da ihre theorien hatten sondern er
selber nimmt das als ein stück
metaphysik hin
und ich glaube nur dadurch
hat er
nur dadurch kann er überhaupt diese
reise mit ihr machen und kann auch nur
dadurch zügelt es sich auch sag mal dass
er sie
weitgehend als als afrikanerin als
mensch steht und nicht als als oder
sammeln erst nur in einem sehr geringen
umfang später als eine frau die er
begehrt ja da muss dazu muss man sagen
sie wird ich habe in dem roman einige
dinge genommen die es in der realität
gegeben hat das sind sozusagen wichtige
referenzpunkte in den punkt das ist
einmal eine
eine show mit afrikanern in einer
tiefgarage in mailand die es gab wo
afrikaner flüchtlings garderobe für
vorgeführt haben als neuen look ja die
gab es tatsächlich
und die spielte hier in dem buch eine
zentrale rolle eine andere sache es gab
noch viele mehr aber eine andere wenig
noch es wurde auf illegale geschossen in
italien und zwar mit kleinkaliber
luftgewehren ja und es wird doch auf sie
geschossen und zwar auf eine stelle an
der sie sich nicht selbst die wunde
versorgen kann gleichzeitig will sie
aber auch nicht zum arzt das heißt er
ist gezwungen dort diese wunde zu
versorgen und
und das ist da ist für mich so dieser
punkt wo
realität und transzendenz eine nach
stelle haben und das war mir sehr
wichtig in diesem buch dafür eine form
zu finden ja es ist ja so dass die die
die literatur
hat hat ja zwei große methoden also das
literarische schreiben einmal
im schreiben eine wahrheit zu finden
oder wahrheit zu finden und sie dann
auch zu erzielen also wahrheiten zu
erzielen heute reden alle vom narrativ
und haben sich das so unter den nagel
gerissen dieses wort das finde ich
furchtbar aber eigentlich geht es darum
nicht mit den mit den methoden die wir
uns heute angeeignet haben also
sozusagen mit der experte meinung etwas
dazu legen sondern mit den mythen mit
den mitteln des erzählens und das war
auch meine anstrengungen hier bei diesem
buch
im grunde sind ja die fotos die dann von
hier entstehen eigentlich auch eine art
von nahtstelle zwischen realität und
transzendenz denn die zeigen zwar nicht
die realität im moment ihres entstehens
also hat sie aufgenommen werden aber sie
zeigen etwas das geschehen ist absolut
ihrem leben sie zeigen eigentlich wenn
man so will erinnerungen ja und wenn man
wenn man dann hat sie vielleicht kann
doch ein schnäppchen geschlagen wenn ich
mich sagen was sind wir denn wir
menschen unter anderem sind wir die
summe unserer unserer erinnerungen
natürlich wenn diese fotos ihre
erinnerungen zeigen eine jeweils davon
da etwas was sie erlebt hat dann sind
sie auf gewisse weise doch ein abbild
für sie zeigen bestandteile ihrer welt
sagen wir mal so bestandteile ihrer
innenwelt und
es ist so dass der ich-erzähler nach
einem geschehen dass ich jetzt hier
nicht im einzelnen erzählen möchte
gezwungen ist das land zu verlassen
zunächst mal fährt er zu einer alten
jugendliebe und hält sich dort auf und
dann reißt er an den ort
von dem diese afrikanerin aufgebrochen
ist und findet auch diese motive dort
wieder ja und das ist glaube ich der
moment wo sich für ihn diese frage dann
gar nicht mehr erstellt
ich habe vorhin eine kleine eine kleine
an route aus rausgehalten aber jetzt
natürlich nicht angebissen
ich habe das wort geständnis oder
beispiel ernst
ich versuche es noch mal noch mal anders
ich will jetzt gar nicht gar nicht auf
das schicksal von cordes und andere
dinge
chinas ich will schon schon bei diesen
beiden bleiben bei diesem bei diesem
seltsamen paar
das durchs land reist sich nicht kennt
sich als mann und frau ausgibt
und versucht sich irgendwie anzunähern
bei aller gebotenen distanz und auch bei
misstrauen und ich frage mich kann das
funktionieren
wenn das beginnt diese diese beziehung
diese bekanntschaft diese freundschaft
oder auch diese
liebe kommt ja kommt ja ins spiel spielt
ja ist wichtig natürlich
entwickelt sich aber kann das
funktionieren wenn es beginnt mit einem
im grunde doppelten betrug ja
das ist eine gute frage
mit doppelter betrug wenn ich das wo du
kannst du moment nachdenken dann erkläre
ich kurz was ich damit meine wieso
doppelter betrug gehabt zum 1
wir haben es ja gehört er sagt ja ja wir
fahren nach rom fährt aber stur seine
alte erinnerungs route weiter täuscht
sie also und das andere ist er sucht sie
ja überhaupt nur um sie an seinen
radiosender zu verscherbeln also ich sie
aber
das gibt er aber
hubert das gibt er aber relativ bald auf
also es gibt einen moment wo er ganz
klar sieht das dass da eine dimension
ist die auch nicht mehr in eine solche
geschichte passt und dass das etwas dass
da etwas stattfindet das größer ist als
er selbst das merkte irgendwann aber
natürlich gibt es diesen gibt es diesen
jahr betrug oder diesen dieses wie soll
ich sagen dass er hinter ihrem rücken
das macht das ist richtig wobei das für
mich am anfang ganz entscheidend war ich
wollte auf keinen fall dass ihr sie zu
sagen dass er sich sozusagen als
gutmensch mitnimmt ja und sondern er hat
erst mal seine eigenen dinge sondern
hast ja vorhin das wort das drehbuch
zitiert ich drehbücher gestellt ich hab
ja ich habe natürlich auch von von guten
drehbüchern amerikanischen gelernt ja
und da fängt niemand als guter mensch an
sondern verändert sich ja und erstmals
ist er meistens ganz schrecklich ja
to have to have not oder so was er
solche sachen aber
das ist richtig und
das geht dann aber so weit dass er ja
irgendwann auch fantasien hat wie er mit
ihr in einer kleinen wohnung leben
könnte ja fast sich eine idylle ausmalt
ja aber auch nicht ihr sondern er deutet
das nur an aber ihm ist glaube ich sehr
schnell klar dass das nicht funktioniert
und dann komme ich auf ein
entscheidendes punkt was eigentlich für
mich beide verbinden was letzten endes
das für mich geheime
thema des das ist die melancholie das
ist auch das was beide verbindet letzten
endes ja er weiß hat man ja gemerkt er
ist jemand der viel weiß aber das ist
sozusagen sein
es ist ein besseres wissen
dass
gekrümmt wird durch die gravitation
eines stärkeren gefühls ja und was dann
übrig bleibt das ist ganz am ende so ein
einblick ins nicht sehr aber das ist
sozusagen
es nützt ihm nichts das zu wissen
sondern
sein tiefes gefühl ist ein anderes und
da hilft das wissen nichts mehr und wir
leben ja in einer zeit wo wir glauben
wenn wir was wissen oder wenn wir die
meinung wenn wir meinungen äußern in
denen unser wissen stattfindet dann ist
alles gut ja aber das ist nur ein teil
der medaille
und ich habe den anderen erzählt
ja
wir leben wir leben in einer zeit
leben auch in einer anderen zeit noch
wir leben in einer zeit
wie soll ich das sagen ich sage ich sag
es mal ganz zurückhaltend die sehr
diskurs freudig ist
das meine ich damit ja ja wir hatten und
haben den mito debatte wir haben
debatten über
sexualisierte gewalt
nicht nur in der filmbranche im theater
überall am arbeitsplatz wir haben
debatten und auseinandersetzungen
konflikte um die flüchtlingsproblematik
um rassismus alltagsrassismus und in
diesen zeiten
schreibst du einen roman den man mit
folgendem satz
zusammenfassen könnte es gibt ja diese
tolle beschreibung des drehs besten
drehbuchs aller zeiten von billy wilder
boy meets girl im einsatz den ich meine
es ein bisschen länger und der lautet
alter weiser mann verliebt sich in junge
schwarze flüchtlings schönheit wir leben
in diskurs vorherigen zeiten
hast du eine besondere neigung sich
angreifbar zu machen
ja den habe ich zweifellos also sagen
wir mal so ich weiß schon nach 45 jahren
schreiben oder veröffentlichen weiß ich
ziemlich gut wie man ein buch schreibt
das einigermaßen wasserdicht ist und das
ist aber für mich nicht besonders
interessant mir ist völlig klar dass
diese geschichte offene flanken hat und
wobei ich jetzt komme ich wieder auf
beichte und bericht ich habe natürlich
ist das auch eine beichte ja aber es ist
dennoch mehr ein bericht weil
er sich immer wieder
dieser methode des berichten sondern
auch seiner sprache
rückversichert sich immer wieder fragt
wie kann ich das wie kann man das
überhaupt erzählen und berichten was
mache ich da also das ist
natürlich hätte man das auch als roman
schreiben können aber das hätte mich
nicht interessiert sondern das was da
geschehen ist ist ja alles hinter ihm
sozusagen erst auf den allerletzten
seiten erreicht das geschehen die
gegenwart ja und das ist für ihn auch
der ganz kritische moment ja und vorher
ist alles geschehen und vieles wird dann
auch immer wieder mal im perfekt erzählt
weil es zurückliegt und immer wieder
fragt er sich wie sieht die sprache aus
mit der man das so sagen kann
dass es geht dass es eben nicht auf
diese kurzformel zu reduzieren es
natürlich weiß ich dass man kann auch
zum beispiel etwas anderes sagen
natürlich geht es in diesem buch um das
scheitern auch ja und dann ist es
natürlich eine wahnsinnige verlockung zu
sagen das ist ein roman über das
scheitern der selbst gescheitert ist
also das ist sehr verlockend ja und mir
ist das völlig klar dass das dass solche
risiken bestehen aber
wenn es für mich oder wenn ich versucht
habe ein bollwerk dagegen zu errichten
das ist meine sprache
das ist die sprache in der das alles
erzählt wird und
wenn man die natürlich aus lässt also
ich sag zum beispiel mal an einer stelle
das sieht als sie im auto kommt auch
wieder das feuerzeug zum spielen da
macht sie das feuerzeug an omi die karte
zuschauen er hat pizza geholt geht auf
das auto und sieht sie darin dem schein
des fahrzeugs und empfindet sie als
anbetungswürdig und da gibt es eine
leerzeile und dann steht dort das
anbetungswürdige ein ausdruck einer
sprach erschöpfung ist in ihm ja und
wenn man das natürlich nicht mit zitiert
dann und das stehen lässt das eine wort
dann wird's problematisch ja
du hast mir erzählt du hast dreieinhalb
jahre an dem roman geschrieben
wenn man sich jetzt überlegt ich will
nicht sagen wer da alles durchs dorf
gejagt wurde aber ein bisschen geht es
in die richtung also wenn man sich
überlegt was für diskussionen geführt
wurden in diesen dreieinhalb jahren mit
welcher heftigkeit mit welcher
aggressivität
mit mit welchem mangel an
verständnis
bereitschaft welchen mangel an toleranz
das geführt wurde egal worum es geht
einfach um sache dass das klima ist der
letzten jahr
hat sich das gebremst oder
hast du das ignoriert oder hat es nicht
im gegenteil er ja ein bisschen bisschen
an also ist doch jeher nicht mal
irgendwie nachts herum tappe und kommen
irgendwelche gesprächsrunden wo
irgendwie jeder seine meinung sagt ja
dann hat mich das eigentlich eher
bestärkt
ein buch zu schreiben was das ausblendet
ja und ein buch zu schreiben also ich
meine ich habe mich immer dafür
interessiert ob
wir die dinge interessiert die schon vor
was weiß ich 500 jahren gegolten habe
und wahrscheinlich haben wir uns
verändert jahren gelten oder 1000 ich
habe mich immer dafür interessiert
über die ungerechtigkeit der natur also
über das körper schicksal ich hatte es
immer interessiert welches schicksal
stellt das damit einem bestimmten körper
und eine bestimmten gesichter die welt
zu kommen
unabhängig von sozialen bedingungen ja
und auch dass das habe ich ja schon in
fanta gemacht und auch das habe ich hier
wieder erzählt also insofern hat mich
dass ich habe das schon sehr zur
kenntnis genommen aber es hat mich eher
bestärkt aber es hat mir auch dieses
digitale delirium in dem wir uns
befinden sehr bestärkt genau das zu
erzählen ja also da dagegenzuhalten
bodo kirchhoff hat gerade gesagt ihn
interessieren immer schon die dinge die
vor 500 jahren gegolten haben so ganz
500 jahre ist noch nicht her aber fast
400 genau stehe ich gerade fest
1621 hat ein geistlicher in oxford ein
buch veröffentlicht dessen titel fast
sprichwörtlich geworden ist der
geistliche hieß roth burton das buch das
ich meine heißt
anatomie der melancholie er hat dieses
buch in drei abschnitte aufgeteilt und
der dritte abschnitt ich weiß nicht ob
das für ihn der wichtigste war
widmet sich der melancholie das ganze
buch sammelt eigentlich nur
stellen gedanken
figuren
zur melancholie und der dritte abschnitt
beschäftigt sich mit der melancholie in
der religion und in der liebe und das
ist natürlich ein interessantes
zusammentreffen denn religion und liebe
und melancholie richtig
genau diese trias hast du ja in diesem
roman auch das ist war mir sehr wichtig
dass du das gesagt das war das völlig
trifft genau zu ja
melancholie und liebe es glaube ich
leicht nachvollziehbar aber wie kommt
die religion ins spiel die religion com
kommt ins spiel weil man auf der einen
seite an etwas glauben möchte an dass
man am ende doch nicht glauben kann und
das ist ja marin seine jugendliebe die
er dann in der ersten zeit nach mailand
besucht für vier wochen die irgendwann
sagt dass sie zwar noch predigt hält
aber das nicht mehr glauben kann die ihn
dann später in afrika besucht und das
ist ja dann die einzige die einzigen
wirklichen liebe szenen spielen sich
dann ja dort ab ja aber
auch nicht triumphal sondern im grunde
tief melancholisch ja also wer
melancholie irgendwie nicht so ganz
aushalten kann
ich meine aber dass literatur immer ein
stück weit auch damit zu tun hat
es gibt aber auch andere szenen in dem
buch ich lese am ende ja ja da kommen
wir auch oft leicht gleich dazu derzeit
ist fortgeschritten ich habe nur eine
sache gefunden die muss ich noch
loswerden weil ich hier so schön fand
sie passt nicht
ganz werden es werden sie sehen aber ein
bisschen halt schon
passt deswegen nicht weil das jetzt in
dem satz den ich gefunden habe um don
juan geht und das ist ja eigentlich kein
don juan also das glauben auch klar
geworden dass ist ja nun wirklich nicht
aber die zweite hälfte satzes passt und
der satz lautet don juan ist ein
melancholiker der entfliehen sein
eigentliches element
gefunden hat in der flucht also ja da
habe ich gedacht das motto das könnte
auch ein satz von dir sein oder richtig
ja absolut ja würde ich dem film voll
voll unterschreiten ja
ich sage aber jetzt ich sage es
vielleicht später noch von wem er ist
kommt man nie darauf kann ich ihnen
garantieren kommt man drauf
jetzt würde ich aber vorschlagen hören
wir noch mal ein paar seiten zum
abschluss ja
er ist inzwischen mit ihr in mailand
ihre schusswunde ist einigermaßen
geheilt und
sie will ja eigentlich in mailand ihren
cousin treffen der sollte erst in rom
sein dann sollte er in georgia sein und
dann in mailand weil er dort bei dieser
geschichte in der tiefgarage dieser show
mit afrikanern mit macht und
sie sollen am abend dort hingehen wissen
aber gar nicht genau wo diese tiefgarage
ist im moment besichtigen sie von außen
den mailänder dom und wer mailand kennt
weiß dass direkt neben dem dom die
galeria ist ja wo man also wunderbare
dinge kaufen kann
tatsächlich eine kathedrale nichts
anderes hatten wir betreten als jeder
wieder mit den händen bei sich war die
galleria vittorio emanuele hat fast den
grundriss eines kreuzes und die höhe
eines gotischen kirchenbaus dazu auch
eine kuppel und die läden rings um den
platz unter der kuppel sind die
teuersten die afrikanerin war vielleicht
nur angelockt von vivaldis jahreszeiten
das wären sie an der blauen schaufenster
markise in strömt an eben das fenster
darunter getreten neben ein paar aus
meinem land der mann gerade dabei ein
telefonat zu beenden es war ein breites
und von der höhe auch noch sie
überragendes schaufenster dennoch war zu
erkennen dass die wenigen ausgestellten
stücke im zentrum ein schulterfreies
marak grünes kleid kosten sollte man
musste schon sehr nah an die scheibe
herantreten um die kleinen zahlen ohne
währungs zeichen auf kaum größeren
mädchen lesen zu können die schnittchen
allenfalls in der umgebung von zwei
taschen zwei blusen und dem einen kleid
das war auch meine nannte sprach etwas
in gedämpftem ton das war herauszuhören
dass es um eine der taschen ging er ein
tischlein in rotem leder fast zum preis
einer ausbildung falls ich meine
vermeintliche junge frau oder geliebte
richtig verstanden hatte was ihre schule
betraf wäre das kleid so viel kosten
sollte dass man bei ihr dafür wohl ein
haus hätte bauen können für mein gefühl
war es jedenfalls nicht der haben um
darin eine auskunft zu erbitten dennoch
sind wir davor stehen geblieben die
dinge im schaufenster hielten uns
einfach vom weitergehen ab ebenso ein
anderes paar die beiden flüsterten jetzt
bis die an dem täschchen interessierte
mit kleinen wedel bewegungen vor der
brust ihren schlussstrich zog wäre der
mann nach einem halben blick auf die
afrikanerin etwas so gut wie
unübersetzbaren vor sich hin sagte nicht
von schlechten eltern
dann zog das paar auch schon weiter zum
nächsten geschäft unter der kuppel die
frauen ob man den blick über die
schulter und knappen ja
und ihr entstandene lücke füllte auf der
stelle ein kindliches wie einer
koreanischen massenhochzeit entsprungen
das pärchen der junge bräutigam ganz in
weiß auch die schuhe machte gleich
bilder von seiner noch jüngeren braut
mit ihm smaragdgrüne kleid als
hintergrund und die art wie beide es an
sahen aber auch die frau an meiner seite
dicht vor der scheibe stand ja war
überhaupt dieses kleid präsentiert war
buchstäblich am seidenen faden hängen
gleichsam schwerelos schweben ruf in mir
rief in mir folgende erinnerung war
lydia und ich vor einem glas schreien
mit dem ausgestellten wohl gewarnt
heiligen klara in der krypta der
nachgeben attenkirchen assisi und lydia
zu mir geneigt mit den worten auf der
haut bestimmt ein alptraum ich sah es da
vor dem schrein stehen schulter an
schulter bis mir die afrikanerin etwas
zu dem kleid halb ins ohr sprach das
seine farbe traumhaft sei fans sie voll
hat sie gesagt und ich glaube es war nur
dieses baut in verbindung mit ihrem um
dicht an meinem ohr das mich veranlasst
hat sie am morgen zu nehmen und mit ihr
zweifellos gegen widerstand aber keinen
großen das so feine geschäft zu betreten
wie ein besonderes paar auf der suche
nach dem besonderen an einem auf
besonderen tag der ältere mann mit einem
weltläufigen helau in die stille eines
holzgetäfelten westens gekühlten
innenraums
ja und wie immer ist es die stille die
einen denken lässt man betrete heilige
hallen auch werde es nur die
räumlichkeiten an der legendären
buchhandlung oder eben eines
holzgetäfelten mailänder modegeschäfts
sind wir betreten sie fast schon auf
zehenspitzen mit dem hello höchstens als
lapsus und regen auch nur leise als
würde uns jedes normal gesprochene wort
als ungeeignete kundschaft verraten und
co da könnte in dem laden den wir
betreten haben die seidenfäden an denen
das traumhafte kleid im schaufenster
hängt zum reichsten bringen auf der
große verkaufstresen war aus altem holz
und es gab eine sitzgruppe um dort wohl
in ruhe einen kauf zu ordern oder nach
nötige klein kleiner änderungen zu
besprechen oder sich einfach wie in dem
lande üblich vor und auch nach dem
geschäftlichen bei einem espresso nahe
zu sein ledersessel die ich schon
angesteuert hatte als ein mann in aller
knappste im anzug aus einem hinteren
kabinett trat er war kaum jünger sich
wenn überhaupt aber mit einer hose die
viel zu kurz war als wäre hier
entwachsen und einem haarschnitt wie in
mein vater noch als verschleppte nach
sie frisur getragen hatte alles an ihm
bei jugendliche und ließ alles an mir
endlich erscheinen was aber nicht weiter
ins gewicht fiel denn kaum hatte er uns
gesehen da er nur noch die afrikanerin
an und das von kopf bis fuß ein maß
nehmen bereits mit den augen sich dabei
jedoch geschäftlich an mich wenden als
wäre sie nur langweilig stumm und
schwarz bitte sagte er in seiner sprache
das ja von verkäufern oft und gern mit
heiteren schwung in dem fall aber mit
leisem vorbehalt gebeugte gebrauchte
wörtchen prägung wie mit drei punkten
dahinter prägung darin stand bei mir
eine lehre genau meine gedanken und auch
aufmerksamkeit lücke in der etwas da
hinten rief zu der noch offenen tür aus
der er gekommen war so schnell dass ich
es nicht erfasste um dann ebenso schnell
in der aller welt sprache zu fragen was
er für mich tun könnte wo doch in dem
laden seitens eines mannes gar nichts zu
tun war außer zu bezahlen nun wir
wollten uns bloß nach etwas erkundigen
sagte ich ob aus geistesgegenwart oder
einer panik hervorgerufen durch die
gesamte atmosphäre des ladens 1 liest
sich das so eng gekleideten vielleicht
gar der besitzer nämlich nach dem ort an
dem heute die mailand fashion week mit
afrikanern eröffnet werde wie wir gehört
hätten eine tiefgarage aber wo in der
stadt und um welche uhrzeit
ein frage eigentlich an das
touristenbüro oder die handelskammer
aber der mann im knappen anzug mehrfach
aufgefallen dass er keine socken trug
nannte den namen eines platzes dort gebe
es ein bürohaus unter dem liege die
garage und ohne dass sich darum gebeten
hätte notierte er den namen auf ein
kärtchen während jemand mit einer großen
dunklen schachtel auf beiden armen aus
dem hinterraum kam einer aus der weißes
seidenpapier inc was an einen kinder
sagt denken ließ jemand der erst nach
ein paar schritten als blasse oder gar
gebleichte asiaten im schwarzen
hosenanzug zu erkennen war alterslos und
auch irgendwie
geschlechtslos sie legte die schachtel
auf den tresen hob den deckel ab und
schlug das feine papier zurück und zum
vorschein kam ein kleid wie das das im
fenster zu schweben schien offenbar
hatte der auf jun und dabei auch
erstaunlich falten arme letzteres ist
mir aufgefallen dass er die mögliche
trägerin des kleides einlud an das
enthüllte heranzutreten etwa durch eine
versteckte außenkamera gesehen von
welcher art ihre blicke auf das objekt
im schaufenster waren die asiaten strich
über den feinen stoff ohne ihn wirklich
zu berühren so dass es etwas von einer
segnung hatte sie erteilte den kleid
ihren segen für sein verlassen des
ladens und mir fiel wieder ein dass es
kosten sollte so viel dass ein kauf an
den ja gar nicht zu denken war an diesem
minuten meine rücklagen spürbar
vermindert hätten nur woran war
überhaupt noch zu denken in dem laden am
ehesten daran wie wir beide die
afrikanerinnen und ich ohne dass man uns
verwünscht wieder aus der tür kämen
vielleicht aber auch daran wie sie in
diesem kleid denn aussehen würde
es vielleicht ein ihr erst seine
bestimmung fände wer weiß denn später
noch wasser in solchen momenten gedacht
hat auf jeden fall ist mein zaudern
bemerkt wurden der falten lose hat sich
zu mir gebeugt und mit einer nähe von
mann zu mann gesagt
man müsse sich zeit lassen vor einer
solchen entscheidung man sollte nichts
übereilen
piano piano sagte er leise und schloss
daran die frage ob wir kaffee wollten
und ich winkte nur ab um die verwicklung
in einen prozess der bereits seine lauf
zu nehmen schien nicht noch zu
vergrößern ich war weder vorbereitet auf
eine entscheidung von solcher tragweite
noch gerüstet dafür nur leute mit
finanzieller reserven sind auf so etwas
vorbereitet sie können allein den
geschmack entscheiden lassen oder einer
laune nachgeben nehmen wir doch das gute
stück warum nicht
der ladeninhaber
davon bin ich jetzt ausgegangen welcher
verkäufer könnte er es sich schon
leisten keine socken zu einem anzug zu
tragen warf mir einen blick zu nach der
allgemeinen formel der peinlichkeit ich
weiß du weißt dass ich weiß dass mein
laden drei nummern zu groß für dich ist
aber deine schwarze schönheit bild
dieses kleid also bitte
und noch mit diesem blick hat er sein
zellulare aus der tasche gezogen und
sich etwas entfernt allerdings nicht um
zu telefonieren während die asiatin eine
sehr pauschale bezeichnung aber sie
hatte eben etwas insgesamt haftet alles
weitere übernahmen sie wandte sich an
die die das kleid tragen sollte ohne
mich dabei erst den augen zu lassen und
erklärte ihr und wofür es sich besonders
eigenen team abend gesellschaften aber
auch ein konzert oder den opernbesuch
und wie sehr es für den hoch gewachsenen
schlanken körper erdacht und
zugeschnitten sein das letzte argument
hat sie durch handbewegungen
unterstrichen wobei sie meinen
generellen einwand gegen den kauf
ebenfalls durch eine handbewegung die
unter umständen missverständlich war
schlicht übersehen hat oder falsch
gedeutet wie auch immer sie baten die
denkbare trägerin des kleides wiederum
durch handbewegungen das rückwärtige
kabinett und die afrikanerin kam dieser
einladung nach einem höchstens halb
fragen den blick zu mir nach der sagen
wir point of no return wenn ich daran
zurückdenke
in dem laden dagegen war es ein moment
idiotischen stolzes als zahlender
begleiter von der die einem solchen
kleid sinn gibt in dem sie alle blicke
darauf zieht mit einer haut die es anja
unvergleichlich macht mode ist eine
sache des blickes und blickfänge trüben
den geist an das ist ja kaum zu
verstehen wie sich ein erwachsener mann
der ladeninhaber der wieder auf mich zu
trat in hochwasserhosen zeigen konnte
eng und oben gekrempelt über den fesseln
enden die sorten losen fesseln zwischen
dem zu frühen ende der hose und die
patchouli farbe den slipper waren denke
ich teil eines gesamtbildes zudem auch
noch ein bier aus ihm heraus blühendes
einstecktuch im veilchen ton seiner
krawatte mit halstuch haft im knoten
gehörte ich versuche hier nur
wiederzugeben was mich womöglich noch
leichtsinniger gemacht hat als es beim
betreten des ladens schon der fall war
und mich ja ohne weiteres als er mir
einen der duftenden ledersessel am boot
platz nehmen ließ spätestens hier
spätestens hier hätte jeder klar
denkende geist gemerkt dass das
geschehen um ihn herum in die verkehrte
richtung geht der inhaber rückte eine
der anderen sessel heran und setzte sich
auf die kante um sich mehr hingegen zu
beugen erst jetzt waren die gestrafften
fältchen auf seiner stirn zu sehen als
feine streifen glückwunsch sagte er
congratulations mit dem akzent der auch
allem ernsten auf eine falsche
leichtigkeit gibt und nach einer pause
erklärt er worauf sich der glückwunsch
bezog kurz gesagt er glaubte in meiner
begleiterin die zu erkennen von der es
nur phantombilder gab er war sich dessen
so sicher zumal ich nach dem ort der
fashion week eröffnung mit afrikanern
gefragt hatte dass er mir für das kleid
ein angebot machte ich konnte es zu
einem sonderpreis bekommen wenn sie es
heute bei der eröffnung tragen würde und
nichts dagegen hätte wenn ab morgen ein
bild von ihr mit dem kleid in seinem
fenster stünde
so überraschend überraschen füreinander
in dem die geschäftswelt völlig
vorbeigeht ist dieses angebot gekommen
dass sie zunächst gar nicht sagen konnte
nur doch um den kaffee bitten der zweite
fehler oder schon der dritte nach dem
betreten des ladens und einem sich
wiegen in stolz als es zur anprobe des
kleides gegen erst als sich die kleine
tasse in händen hielt und der
ladeninhaber wieder ganz jugendlich auf
der sessel kannte sagt faste ich mich
etwas und kam auf den sonderpreis zurück
einerseits aus neugier andererseits und
das war der eigentliche fehler weil ich
mir meine gefährten der letzten zwei
wochen zunehmend in dem kleid vorstellte
quanto fragte ich und idee zusammen muss
man wissen dass der ausgewiesene preis
in den so diskret kleinen ziffern glatte
1800 betragen hat gleichwohl habe ich
die afrikanerin schon bei abend
gesellschaften neben mir gesehen auch
wenn es solche anlässe in meinem leben
gar nicht gibt eine augenblicks vision
die nach dem ersten schluck kaffee in
die wirklichkeit übersprang als sie
nämlich in dem kleid wie in etwas
wahrhaft traumhaften oder himmlischen
aus dem hinteren raum trat dazu
allerdings ihre sehr irdischen
laufschuhe trug
half preis sagte der inhaber zu mir
gebeugt das hieß 900 ein betrag der
mehrzahl vor augen stand und ich sagte
7z und er sagte 8 sogar in meiner
sprache und boden wir die hand zum
abklatschen an was ja schneller und
geschmeidiger geht als ein händedruck
nur blieb meine hand in der luft während
mir die in dem kleid ein zwei vereinen
die blicke zuwarf zwischendurch aber
auch ein zwei bejahende über einen band
spiegel sie sah fantastisch aus wenn ein
so leeres wort hier erlaubt ist und
unter genau diesem eindruck schlug ich
meine hand in dieses falten losen und
kam dabei aus dem sessel um aus der nähe
zu sehen was sie soeben gekauft hatte
schönheit wird für einen mann vermutlich
gilt das auch für frauen zum ein und
alles sobald sie sich ihm zuneigt ihn
damit glauben lässt die unglaubliche
schönheit mit erschaffen zu haben wie
großartig siehst du aus dem kleid das
ich dir schenken zeig dich damit an
meiner seite dann gehört uns die welt
ich fürchte ich fürchte solche oder
ähnliche worte sind wir aufgestiegen wie
wasser oder denkt leichen ich sagte der
afrikanerin wie günstig dieser kauf sei
sie müssen sich keine gedanken machen
und sie sagte noch mit blick in den
spiegel leser meiner entscheidung allein
meine das heißt hier war die ganze
situation der vornehme laden und die
asiaten mit herren frisur sowie der
falten loser inhaber im engen anzug ohne
socken weniger über den kopf gewachsen
als mir auch wenn sie das im rücken
ausgeschnitten begleiten noch größer
machte als sie ohnehin war und in den
spiegel schauen ließ als schaute sie auf
sich herunter ein von der asiatin auf
fingerzeig des inhabers mit
taschenspieler after geschwindigkeit
festgehaltenes bild die trägerin des
leiters noch abgelenkt vom eigenen
anblick schien davon nichts bemerkt zu
haben sie war erst wieder bei der sache
als es darum ging ob das kleid an
kritischen stellen auch richtig sitzt
oder kleine änderungen bedürfte das
heißt als der falten lose auf sie zutrat
um den sitz seines besten stücks zu
prüfen sicher ein üblicher vorgang bei
solchen käufen die kunden muss es nur
wissen muss daran gewöhnt sein dann wird
sie den prüfenden griffen sogar 1 gegen
kommen auch mit kleinen hinweisen unter
den aktien könnte es weiter sein um die
teil hier durchaus etwas enger doch ist
es anders gelaufen doch während der
hochwasserhosen die arme in richtung des
kleides und damit der trägerin streckte
sagte sie leise don't touch
leise auf eine art die in sofort die
hände zurück ziehen ließ und sie mit den
fingerspitzen aufeinander zu legen und
erst mich dann seine assistentin und
zuletzt auch die die ihn gestoppt hatte
anzusehen loni mit andere sagte er das
ganze in spaßige bildete ziehen die
prüfung anschließend mit den augen zu
erledigen er ging einmal um die reglos
in dem kleid dastehen darum am ende mit
einer andeutung von applaus was jetzt
noch fehle seien passende schuhe und der
empfahl mir ein geschäft in der näheren
umgebung meiner afrikanerin aber meine
das hatte ich nach dem down touch me mit
absurdem stolz so empfunden machte
zeichen dass sie ihre schuhe anbehalten
wollte aber auch gleich das kleid also
die schuhe zu dem kleid oder das kleid
zu den ausgetretenen adidas schuhen was
auf jeden fall ist dass sie das kleid
nicht wieder ausziehen würde um es in
der schachtel mit zunehmender dass sie
nicht einmal die iv eine schachtel mit
den insignien des ladens wollte weil
ihre vorherige kleidung die kinos aus
protonen und das t shirt mit den
chinesischen schriftzeichen in ihr
bündel stopfte als wäre der ganze
kleiderkauf nur einer unterbrechung auf
ihrem langen weg gewesen den sie in dem
kleid fortsetzen wollte und dann sagte
sie auch noch wieder mit dem mund nah an
meinem ohr dass wir jetzt durch die
stadt gehen könnten und mailand ansehen
was alles in allem bei dem ladenbesitzer
erst zu einem kopf wiegen schnell aber
zu einer weiteren andeutung von applaus
geführt hat der kunden als königin zu
gedacht auch wenn ich der könig mit dem
kärtchen war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja all jene unter ihnen die jetzt denken
kann mir nicht passieren meint ist weit
muss ich waren sagen fühlen sich nicht
allzu sicher ich sage nur ein wort
goethestraße
das soll aber nicht das letzte wort sein
hauke hückstädt hat am anfang zu recht
wirklich zu recht darauf hingewiesen
dass es nicht um ein komplexes buch
handelt ich glaube davon ist jetzt ein
eindruck entstanden
und ich werde jetzt nicht aufzählen was
wir alles nicht erwähnt haben das würde
lange lange dauern
paar beispiele will ich nur geben wir
haben nichts vom schauplatzwechsel
besprochen denn fast nicht ausführlich
afrika wir haben nicht von herrn cordes
gesprochen dass es mit ihm auf sich hat
wir haben nicht gesprochen von der
kindheit freundin waren im schwarzwald
der im heiliger ort im heiliger ort ja
wir haben auch nicht gesprochen von
denen von der
erzählweise von der von der art wie hier
mit den zeit- ebenen gearbeitet wird
sind nämlich vier verschiedene
zeitebenen oder vielleicht sogar fünf
wenn man die zeit mit lydia die erste
reise auf die er immer wieder rekurriert
wird vor zehn jahren wie man die dazu
nimmt sind zwar fünf zeit ebenen
über all das haben wir nicht gesprochen
aber ich glaube wir haben über viele
sachen gesprochen die wichtigen sachen
haben wir angeregt
angeschnitten
für mich ist das ja
ein bericht zur lage des glücks einmal
heißt es glück ist ein wort das es nur
im singular gibt
für mich ist das der bericht eines
fliehenden und
vor was dieser mann alles flieht
das ist wieder ein anderes thema das
können sie selber herausfinden wenn sie
lesen
sie sollten das buch lesen sie sollten
ein signiertes exemplar lese
wäre mein vorschlag die
gelegenheit ist günstig bodo kirchhoff
für draußen hauke hückstädt hat
angekündigt draußen signieren
wir sind am ende des abends angelangt wo
du musst noch ein bisschen arbeiten
da bleibt mir noch ihnen zu danken für
ihre geduld dafür dass sie hier waren
und natürlich danke ich vor allem
produktiv vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]